How's everybody doing?
Very good.
Good, colored friends so far?
Learning everything?
Alright, so.
If you've ever heard me before,
my name is Dr. Kevin Codders,
I practice in Minnesota.
Tets like accent, but people kind of adore
a w接ure accent up here okay
a little bit.
So if I send you a bed job,
or any of that you know why.
I see醫utches,
in line patients, some really sick autoimmune patients.
I have a pretty good website.
If you haven't been on our website,
probably have at least a hundred videos on our website.
I like to teach.
So hopefully I can make this really boring subject
exciting today.
Now I'm open to teaching whatever you want to learn about.
So we're going to open up to some questions
and if you have specific questions to what I'm talking about,
feel free to ask them, but I might be able to get to everybody.
So we're going to be talking about some hidden, hidden causes
of disease and we're going to be talking about genetics.
Doesn't that sound fun?
Yes.
Woo-hoo.
So your DNA as a hidden cause of disease.
All right, are you ready?
I was really nervous.
I told my staff, and I got about 60 slides
and it's going to be all on genetics.
I'm just spreading it on the board.
Everybody to tears.
So I see there's only a few open seats
by the time I'm done.
It'll probably be half empty.
So I'm going to apologize right up front.
So I really like looking at people's genes.
And after I talk, I hopefully you'll go,
wow, I want to look at my genes too,
because it can make a big difference in getting a person better.
Most of my patients that come to me are in a situation
where they're either really sick stage four cancer.
That's about 80% of our cancer patients come in at stage four.
They've tried chemotherapy, they've tried radiation,
they've done surgery, and they've been given a timeline.
Most of them.
And I'm not a healer.
I believe I'm just a doctor, which I believe
my responsibility is to pray for wisdom constantly.
And then to walk in that wisdom is best I can.
And just be in one of the things
when I pray for wisdom for myself
is that God always drives me to study.
So when we talk about genetics,
I have some comp gene defects that you'll see in the later.
So I have a little OCD with my study,
and I have no other life, but that's the way it is.
But I like it.
So we go out of occasion, and my wife says,
okay, lay down and rest for a little bit.
That lasts for about five minutes
that I have to get up and read a book.
So that's just the way God wired me.
So when I see patients that have gone everywhere else
and can't get better, boy, that seems
that's a heavy responsibility.
And to me, that is a responsibility.
So when God sends us a patient, I believe that in a certain sense,
I got to figure this out.
And so I'm always searching for other missing pieces
in the puzzle.
So when we talk about genetics,
I think this is a big missing piece of the puzzle
in a lot of people's cases.
They've gone to functional medicine, doctors,
they've gone to good functional chiropractors
and natural paths, and they've done,
you know, adrenal work and thyroid work,
and all this different kind of stuff.
But there's something that they're missing.
So I've spoken at other life conferences
and talked about immunology.
That's another big missing piece of the puzzle
that I believe that most doctors don't understand.
We're not gonna be able to talk about that
at this time, we don't have the time,
but go on our website, if you have Lyme disease,
I have a lot of really good videos on what I believe
that there's three stages of Lyme, not just two,
that you can, that will help you understand that.
Also, I have books out there.
I think I only have the cancer books left.
But please, no, on our website,
all my books are downloadable free.
So you can get my books for free on our website.
Yes, what's our website?
Right there.
www.connersclinic.com.
So I give all our information for free.
So this video that's gonna be made here,
I'll get it, and I'll actually put
Snipsib it up on our website too,
because I really believe that an educated person
can take responsibility for their own disease
and can make better decisions.
So I do not want to be in a co-dependent relationship
with my patients, I don't want them to depend upon me.
I want to educate them as much as I can
so that they can make their own decisions.
So I try to put all the information up on our website,
so I think you can spend about two weeks on my website,
just watching things.
It probably kill you, or boredom, but you couldn't do that.